issues that arise at work are often a
reflection of problems occurring in the
larger society and the tensions that
we're seeing out there today so today
unfortunately all around the world were
seeing conflicts sometimes verbal
attacks sometimes physical attacks maybe
it's refugees from Syria or other
war-torn countries trying to find a
place to live in Europe maybe it's a tax
on immigrants maybe in the United States
now it seems to be a tax on religious
groups Muslims sometimes now we're
seeing racial conflicts arise again so
we thought it would be useful in this
course to have a conversation about how
these conflicts then affect the
workplace and what if what we've learned
over the years about how to address them
effectively and we're fortunate to have
a world-class expert here to draw on I'm
talking today with Professor mary rowe a
friend and colleague here in the Sloan
School mary has been the ombudsperson
for MIT for 40 years and she's now
taking time to reflect on the lessons
she learned from that experience and its
implications for how we can move forward
so Mary thank you for joining us today
my pleasure so why don't we start right
at the bait at the beginning what is an
ombudsman or Ombudsperson or Ombuds
whatever the appropriate term is and
what does a person in that role do an
organizational on but and there's lots
of us now around the world I'm guessing
that they're probably about a thousand
of us in corporations and government
agencies and academic institutions
around the world I'm it's in neutral
many people know what a mediator does
and if you can imagine an internal
mediator who works on any kind of
problem that comes to him or her that
begins the picture we're independent of
all line and staff offices by standards
of practice we report to the chief
executive officer or above him or her to
aboard we're informal we
don't have any management power we can't
fix anything and we are confidential
that's perhaps the most important thing
for your for your talk today we keep no
case records for our organizations
anybody can we're called as zero barrier
office we should establish an office
where there are no barriers at all to
being able to come to talk with us well
that's a good introduction and i know
you have emphasized the need for
multiple tools to fit into what you have
called a conflict management system
could you describe what some of these
tools are that are needed for people in
your role to be effective well people in
my role need various kinds of tools we
think of a sense of humor integrity
intelligence caring especially important
especially because of what you were
saying before about the origins of
conflict we think of Ombudsman is
needing to have a lot of cross-cultural
experience and indeed my profession is
one of the best integrated professions
in the world by race and by gender I'm
very proud of that but I think you're
also thinking about what needs to be in
an organizational system to deal with
with conflicts in the workplace and with
students and so on is that right that's
right some of the tools and the options
that I know you consider important lots
of people who think about this question
think first about do we have a formal
grievance procedure and that of course
is a very important question for the
most grievous problems and the ones that
need a management decision but most
problems will yield two people thinking
about their own interests and those of
others at what people at what
organizations think of is the lowest
possible level so at the lowest possible
level we want conflict settled on site
if possible and in the last end of the
line we would think of formal grievance
procedures and then there are lots and
lots of steps in between mm-hmm and some
of those steps really empower
individuals to deal with conflicts more
effectively and i know you have spent a
lot of time working to help individuals
figure out what options are best for her
or for him in in addressing these what
would some of those options be when
people think about Ombuds and or when
they think about taking an Ombuds they
often think about conflict management or
just as dispute resolution a given
dispute comes and they step in with a
magic wand and fix it I in point of fact
very good Ombudsman place for a long
time generally spend more than half
their time helping people help
themselves to learn how to deal with
conflicts and even to prevent them and
that's true for both individuals and for
groups so helping people help themselves
listening to people talk about their
issues getting them to articulate their
concerns having more formal consultation
in organizations and forums for affinity
groups and maybe sometimes councils of
people coming together these are all
part of a larger system that i know you
have emphasized do we have room for me
to tell a quick story sure you know i'm
just looking back at my old papers in
the 1970s and 80s I was a young
economist and I came from the outside to
MIT I was overwhelmed by having a
hundred people come to me in my first
week no two of them with the same issue
and I didn't have any expertise on any
one of them but what I did do with the
total backing of my boss the president
was to get any two people who had the
same issue together with each other to
try to figure out what kind of systems
change might help deal with that issue
or even prevent it now here's what I
just discovered in those 17 years there
were at least sixty women's groups alone
and many minority groups I haven't yet
got a perfect count of them
and many cohort groups like engineering
assistance you've got themselves
together to as affinity groups if you
will to propose solutions to so that's
just one example of what you're seeing
well I like the emphasis that you put on
systems that these different options
need to be there because people have
different preferences for how they
approach these issues and you have been
very skillful in helping people find
something they're comfortable with and I
think that's really critical to making
these work but you've also developed
this concept of micro inequities and
we've heard about microaggressions but
you've kind of turned that into ways to
to deal with these in in positive ways
what are micro inequities and then we
can talk about how to perhaps deal with
them but this is something that I think
is particularly unique to to your own
work I was very honored before and just
after I came to MIT to have as a mentor
dr. Chester Pierce many people nowadays
remember him a very prominent
psychiatrist and neurologist Chad Pierce
came up with the idea of micro in micro
aggressions in 1970 talking about racism
and talking about hostile acts and he
was simply extraordinary and helping to
develop that idea when I came to MIT I'm
very grateful to him for what I had
learned about microaggressions i find i
found microaggressions and of course we
still do but i found a great deal more
besides there are hostile acts as all of
us know and there's a great deal of
small acts of racism and religious
intolerance and sexism and so on in
addition though I discovered a lot of
complaints and concerns that appear to
me to arise out of out of unconscious
bias that is to say not available to the
person who is behaving in a way that he
or she might even regret
and in 1973 I found myself doing this
and in fact my kids were simply
delighted to catch me doing it so
unconscious bias was a big deal for me
and then I began to discover these
little aggressions or inequities if you
will that seemed to arise just out of
negligence I knew better but I just blew
it and then finally there was a large
clump of them again problems that were
promised for me myself that arose out of
what i will call innocent ignorance a
lot of ignorance is not innocent but I I
lived in west africa just before I came
I inadvertently served food with my left
hand to Muslim colleagues I made the
mistake of showing the bottom of my foot
in a meeting and in a very polite Muslim
meeting in West Africa I learned that
it's very easy to be very offensive on
the basis of problems that one just
didn't know exist so with great respect
and with chapters is blessing I extended
the idea of microaggressions to include
these other huge groups of problems
sexism as well as racism and just plain
bullying as well as either yeah so these
micro inequities often are happening
even though we're not always aware of
them but you've tried to make this a
more positive approach to addressing
these issues and you call them micro
affirmations tell us what you mean by
that give us some examples of how one
can deal with these micro inequities
again it was partly in an effort to to
make sure that I was myself not
committing if you will Michael
inequities right and left I and here was
my problem tom I thought to myself if
some of these problems come from
unconscious bias and there's no way we
can be aware without a lot of work at
least to be aware of our own
unconscious bias wow what hope is there
for me so I read and I thought I
psychology gave me a clue which is that
if one always behaves in a respectful
way and seeks out that which can be
affirmed in everything around one in
one's work group always genuinely of
course things that really are going well
if one's whole life has spent in genuine
affirmation of other people's excellence
and in respectful behavior you can block
your own unconscious bias so my first my
first thought about affirmations was
really in an effort to do something
about myself it turns out the microwave
firm ations have a whole lot of other
good aspects to them they make people
happy the work of the negotiation
project on core emotional concerns shows
that approval and affirmation are two of
the most important core emotional
concerns that every single person has
all over the world and if I live my life
in micro affirmations I am by definition
reaching out to the core emotional
wishes of everybody I'm interacting with
and those are just two of them you'll
have a chart those are just two of the
ways that micro affirmations can be
helpful so by affirming good behavior
and recognizing it and providing
psychological rewards and role modeling
in your own behavior you often make it
contagious for others in one's work
group it sounds like this is the way in
which you show by creating an
environment of support that we aren't
going to tolerate in equities and you
change attitudes by changing behavior
exactly so we've known for a long time
that attitudes affect behavior more
recently we've learned that our behavior
can change our own attitudes that's a
big deal I think that's a really
important point and
and it has good psychological research
basis but it also just makes good common
sense that we learn from each other's
experience at young ages in in our
workplaces as well so that's that's very
helpful but I want to turn to another
idea that you have championed and used
so effectively over the years and that's
something that we call bystanders that
you call bystanders in particular and
we're all bystanders and we see bad
things happening in our workplace and
our wherever we are in society and we
come home in the next morning and the
shower we say gee I wish I would have
done something tell us what you've
learned about how to be an effective
intervener and went when one sees them
in a bystander role and see something
bad happening at the workplace I
bystanders have a bad name all over the
world and in fact the term bystander
effect is often used to mean somebody
who stands by and let's racism or unsafe
behavior or something terrible happen I
when I began looking at all of this I
began looking at it from the point of
view of an ombudsman because we're very
bad things or very good things happen in
the workplace usually there's no
supervisor there but there are peers and
bystanders so I thought here is enormous
leverage either in getting wonderful
recognition for good behavior or in
getting unacceptable behavior stopped so
I began to study it first of all the
bystander effects the so-called
bystander effect it was studied in a
very narrow context and even in that
context it isn't always the case but so
what my standards actually do when they
see something unacceptable or scary it
could be a safety problem it could be a
mistake it could be an error or it could
be really unacceptable personal behavior
or group behavior most bystanders
funnel very quickly through a great many
options and this is really the point of
where I'm coming to those who run
organizations usually think of
bystanders as either doing nothing or
reporting immediately to the authorities
those that meaning responsible
bystanders do nothing or i guess the
they don't do anything and if they're
responsible they only report to
authorities in real life bystanders do
all kinds of other things and I began to
study that from my last 15 years as a
nun but I collected everything that
people told me in my office that they
had considered when they saw either
wonderful behavior or terrible behavior
what options did they consider and it's
very rare that they considered going to
authorities and mostly they did want to
act so they came up with lots of other
possible options for how to get
something fixed or prevented or
remediated mm-hmm what would some of
those options be obviously it means one
has to sort of disrupt the behavior in
in real time in some way or change the
behavior so can you give us an example
or examples of of actions that you've
seen people take that have been
effective well again your question is a
perfect one because in real life people
often don't act on the spot in the
moment they think about it and they
think they might act on the spot in the
moment but they think about it and they
worry about it this is the responsible
bystander again some of the options they
choose would be to go home and talk with
trusted family or in the workplace with
trusted friends and peers or if they
have a boss that they really trust they
might ask about it hypothetically like
boss if something like this were to
happen what would you think about it
what could the organization do with a
problem like this I other possibilities
would be that they would get a genera
approach to deal with it if it's an
organization that does a lot of training
maybe a training program but can be
brought in in which we just happen to
mention this kind of behavior I
sometimes a person will act but only
together with a co-worker so Tom I'm
thinking know who do I trust in my
workplace who would come with me to talk
with a boss I wonder if I could write a
note I wonder if there's any manager who
cares about this kind of behavior
sometimes it might be audit for example
or it might be the EEO office maybe I
could write a note and have them I think
about this kind of problem in my section
of my organization so there are lots and
lots of different options that
responsible bystanders will choose well
I like the the way in which you describe
how you talk with people to generate
options like this maybe really skilled
people or people who have a mindset can
interrupt behavior on the spot but often
it's reflecting okay what could I do
tomorrow what could I do today in
retrospect and it's finding those
different approaches that's so key so if
I'm hearing you right Mary what you're
saying is organizations really need to
have respected independent neutrals who
are supported by a conflict management
system with multiple options because
people have different approaches to
dealing with workplace problems and they
need different outlets for addressing
them and then secondly they need to have
tools and training so that not only are
the professionals good at addressing
these issues but so are managers and so
our frontline employees so that they can
be ready to put these tools to use and
they have to trust these tools and then
third you have to create a culture in
the organization that empowers people to
take action sell themselves and how
fathers safely so do you have any final
thoughts on how we can put all these
tools to use to deal with the modern
problems that we see in in workplaces
today I have two final thoughts one is
if you who are listening to this it's
just an individual by yourself and maybe
even young and you think you have no
power you always have options just one
person to make things better wherever
you are if you who are listening to this
are a manager think about a systems
approach with your organ within your
organization to help other people to
help you with a strategic plan to build
an affirming workplace well Mary thank
you very much thank you for all that you
do and all that you have done not only
here in our organization but around the
world to help others build these kinds
of systems and capacity and so there's
lots of issues to address and we just
have to stick with it so thank you very
much thank you Tom